[Music]
what's going on reject nation it's
correct Alva here with Arianna Bob no we
can't no it's too late I'm confident our
doubt of Bathory hasn't been on this
channel in quite some time now she's a
longtime friend so it's like 15 younger
younger like 14 I fight when I was 9 we
all do you're like 14 years old didn't
we start 14 posing for John's yeah that
was one of my lure by my first kiss I
was well that pilot you wrote oh yeah
yeah yeah I've gotten any girl to kiss
Greg also on my mom be in it she was
there thank you for pet die like stay
awake everybody all right on a badass
razor is having Twitter handle and she
is Arianna ba Suri on YouTube go follow
her there links in the description box
so yeah I need attention my friend
Tyrone Magnus did a reaction to a video
that a lot of people had sent over
amazing Tyrone saw this as he was
cracking up you got to watch this video
as I said fine and I thought okay ariana
is the perfect person who watches with
puppy pees and girls now well there's no
you know mystery so what this is going
to be I'm sure you've been in this
situation before Ariana let's do this oh
mama
are we done man see how much we save a
bit narrow but the local silk with the
illest at local doughnut blow itself up
here to do my hometown movin on so Pam I
should speak before
[Music]
no sorry
jesus said brutally nice music plan I
mean it highest Rinna's grow warrior
issues before ok issues the whole thing
was crazy
right like the singing in the you didn't
like her like her vibe okay not her
looks just her energy yeah I wouldn't
criticize her looks good good you're a
good human being Haryana it seems like
she knew this was going to happen I
don't think you took this video she
posted the video might have been a live
stream huh get it with a hey I do
matters and when the dog pees in her
mouth she she seemed surprised seems she
had to register what just came out of
that dog's penis do I have to play a
hack for if he was pretty clear but she
did it I felt like she was in shock at
first where I wouldn't the dog peed in
her mouth she would have to take a
moment to register like was that just
pissed that just went in my mouth and
then she started to defecate
wait now defecate yes okay Serco by
Robert sorry smart word yeah I don't do
that artists that are a lot of vomit so
what was my work for throwing up John
Pearl Jaq what's all wrong
huge dotnet defecate yeah yeah this is
defecation defecate what they by once if
you read the doctor and they're like
readers know that's like a big gag well
it's just discipline yeah what are you
what are you here for John well this
video was absolutely disgusting that
that definitely lived up to I don't
think I found it as funny as people
hoped I would find it
that is just truly disturbing I hate it
when an animal just pees on me how often
does this happen too often are my don't
touch your cats I don't know what you're
like what you don't like cat my cats
only pee on every other person they're
not going to pee on you yes they don't
touch them they respect the Jewish
community it's only Catholics right baby
yeah you can't forget that I only wait
for the cameras rolling to bring it up
yeah literally you never ever talk a lot
we'll make no jokes anymore okay only
Jew issues we don't have a big enough
Jewish holiday we can gather the
analytics can tell it's just Jewish or
not that's their first returning video
is already on that today happier so no
you shouldn't be disappointed to
subscribe to her it'll reject this is a
quick bad notification about hey more
importantly follow Arianna badassery on
Instagram and Twitter and check out her
YouTube channel she's a really funny
woman I'm gonna watch her perform comedy
again she'd right stand up does
something that I'm totally afraid you've
done it before but I done it before
doing it before you face the fear I have
faced the fear but you do it
consistently and you get better and
better sometimes though I do that when
did this I don't have a specific date
and well something didn't have remember
the positives not the negative I only go
up this is why we see each other every
six months
[Laughter]